I think every man in here should get a
colonoscopy because I had to because the
best news you can find out from getting
a camera stuck up your butt is learning
you didn't need to have a camera stuck
up my wife had a brain tumor it was
removed
everything's good the tumor is gone
along with my ability to ever win
another argument I joke around but it
was scary we have five children and
there were moments when I was like oh my
gosh if anything happens to my wife
those five kids are gonna be put up for
adoption visit some places music alright
there's a language barrier but I could
get by and China I was like oh if I got
lost I would die here the entire time I
was in Japan I felt overweight like as I
am overweight to be a really fat in
Japan they make you sumo wrestle they
make their fat people fight each other
[Music]
you